you all know that this is not a conspiracy
theory program.
I am not particularly conspiratorial by my
nature, so today I have to tell you that the
Nevada state election of the Nevada democratic
party has hired a former P Buddha judge staffer
after Buddha judge behaved weirdly when it
came to the Iowa caucus.
Now I am not saying that this is part of a
concerted effort for Pete boot edge edge to
steal the Nevada caucus.
I am telling you that it's evidence of the
way to incest incestuous nature of politics
in the United States and how the same people
keep showing up in too many places.
For my comfort and this is a story in that
it is getting a lot of attention and we have
to figure out what it is that is and is not
going on.
I will tell you what I know.
I will tell you what the Nevada state democratic
party has said and then you tell me what you
think.
The Nevada democratic party hired a former
paid P Buddha judge organizer to be their
voter protection director.
Her name is Emily Goldman.
When you looked at her LinkedIn page yesterday,
you saw that she started a job this month
as voter protection director for the Nevada
state democratic party.
Her last job until starting this one up to
and including this month was organizer for
boot edge edges campaign Pete for America.
This already just doesn't look great given
the theories that are floating around about
the connections between pizza and the Iowa
caucus and the developer of the app that was
used to train a transmit results.
Even without going conspiratorial the way
some people are doing, it just doesn't look
good.
People notice this yesterday and it started
to get attention yesterday and it didn't look
good to a lot of people.
Emily Goldman also tweeted late last week,
some personal professional news.
I've joined the Nevada state democratic party
as their voter protection director.
DM me if you're interested in volunteering
to help us ensure that every voter is able
to get the assistance they need.
As soon as this blew up, Emily Goldman has
locked her Twitter account.
You now have to, uh, she has to accept you
in order for you to see her tweets and also
completely removed her employment history
from her LinkedIn altogether.
And if you go now and look at her LinkedIn
profile, there is no employment history.
It just skips right to her educational history,
no record of working for Pete.
And then the Nevada democratic party, no matter
what you think about nefarious forces working
behind the scenes to steal the election in
Nevada for Pete Buddha, judge, this just looks
bad.
And of course the most likely explanation
for her scrubbing the LinkedIn and then making
her Twitter private is that she's getting
harassed and bullied.
Uh, that that to me makes much more sense
than she thinks that by doing that this controversy
is going to go away because clearly it's not.
So let me be like extra clear, crystal clear.
I think if you have a good plan to steal the
Nevada caucuses for Pete boot edge edge, you
don't have to hire people who worked for him
to vote to go and work for the party in Nevada.
You do it in a more sophisticated way with
technology or with people whose work history
wouldn't directly point to Pete, Buddha, judge
anyone clever enough to steal the caucus wouldn't
have to resort to such an obvious attention
grabbing tactic in order to steal the Nevada
caucus.
The Nevada democratic party was asked about
this.
They put out a statement saying that Emily
Goldman's position is going to handle planning
for the general election in November and that
she has no decision making role in the upcoming
caucuses on February 22nd and even if she
did, they say there's no one person in a role
like this who could actually affect or change
the results.
That's their position.
Another point to mention is that if you actually
want to steal the election with dirty tricks,
it's true that even if she were involved in
the caucuses on the 22nd the voter protection
director probably isn't the person you need
since they are unlikely to actually be able
to mess with vote totals or do the things
that are being alleged were done in Iowa by
the people who believe those theories, but
it just looks terrible and it's more about
the fluidity with which people move between
working for candidates and the party, which
is actually not unusual.
People move all the time between candidates
and party.
Think back to the 2016 Republican primary
into the general election.
Sean Spicer was RNC, I believe it was communications
director or something during the Republican
primary.
He moved very swiftly into voting for Donald
Trump.
It happens both ways, but when the democratic
party nationally has been accused in 2016
and now in 2020 of working to help certain
candidates at the expense of others, people
are obviously going to react this way and
of course are going to be more suspicious.
Then you add to this that Nevada was scheduled
to use the exact same app that imploded in
Iowa for their upcoming caucus but have since
changed their minds and things look weird
and they one could surmise motive to figure
out other ways to take control of the caucus
given that the app will not be used.
So I understand why people are flipping out.
The reality is there's lots of DNC people,
uh, and party people working for Biden and
vice versa.
Anybody with establishment connections is
likely to have the employment fluidity going
on.
Tell me what you believe.
And I think it's really important, you know,
once we start saying not that the DNC has
a preference, which obviously they do and
we talked about in 2016 once we start saying
there is a conspiracy to manipulate vote totals,
we are crossing a line that is a very significant
line to be crossing.
And so what I want to hear from you is what
you make of this is this the incestuous nature
of party politics in the United [inaudible]
States.
Is it more nefarious?
Let me know.
I'm on Twitter at D Pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
and boy do we have a full one for you today,